i've been a fan of apple's macbook pro
for years now
for various reasons ranging from the
excellent build quality
to the mac os software and it isn't very
common for a windows laptop
to make me disappointed in my macbook
pro
but that's exactly what happened with
the brand new 2020
razer blade stealth 13. so in this video
i'm going to take a look at this laptop
from a macbook user's point of view
since that's what i own and i love and
so far
i'm really impressed from the first time
i unboxed this new razer laptop
i noticed that the build quality felt
very similar to the macbook pro
thanks to the all metal design which is
very solid
my only issue with it is the black
finish which is such a fingerprint
magnet
that i've given up on trying to keep it
looking clean but i absolutely love
the one-handed open hinge which is
something i really enjoy about my
macbook
so good job razer you nailed it on the
build quality front
and to make it even better it supports
windows hello
so it logs you in as soon as you open it
no need to enter a password or touch the
fingerprint sensor
like the macbook pro forces you to do
now with the razer's display open
the keyboard and trackpad layout looks
almost identical to the macbook pro
and i honestly love that about it since
it feels so familiar
as far as the keyboard i like the
keyboard feel better on the razer
since it seems to have more key travel
and a good amount of feedback as well
and one thing that i really don't like
on the macbook pro is the touch bar
i really wish apple never released it
because
the function keys on the blade stealth
are so much better
and it's also nice to see that the razer
gives us customizable rgb keyboard
backlighting as well
as for the trackpad i'm happy to see
razer using up all of the space
available instead of making it smaller
but going from a force touch trackpad on
the macbook
to a traditional diving board style kind
of sucks
but it's still better than a lot of
other windows laptops and i fully
understand that apple has patented the
force touch trackpad
so razer's doing the best with what
they've got now when i compared the
speakers between them
the macbook pro was the clear winner in
terms of sound quality
however the razer packed just as much
volume which is very important to me
when i'm watching
shows or youtube videos so here's a
short clip so you can hear it for
yourself
as far as the ports the razer gives you
the best of both worlds
compared to the macbook pro which
strictly gives you four thunderbolt 3
ports to work with
the razer actually gives you two usb a
ports and two
usb c ports one of which supports
thunderbolt 3
and i find that to be the perfect
combination for any situation
now finally getting into the display
this is where i found
a major downside but also a huge upside
the downside is that the display has a
massive chin
or bottom bezel thanks to razer choosing
to stick to a 16x9 aspect ratio
and once you see this chin you can't
unsee it
and it bothers me every time i look at
it but what i'm very happy about is the
freedom
razer gave us to choose the display we
want
if you want a premium ultrabook but you
want to save some money
you can get the standard 1080p display
and if you're a gamer
you can choose the 120hz display to take
advantage of high frame rate gaming
thanks to that dedicated gtx 1650 ti
graphics card
which i'll get into in a moment and if
you're a creative professional
you can buy the 4k display with
excellent quality
for things like photo and video editing
and it even comes with touch screen
support
this makes the razer blade stealth
perfect for those three markets
so while the large bottom bezel is a bit
disappointing
razer nailed the display options and
with that
let's get into performance i'm happy to
see that this laptop comes loaded with
up-to-date specs like intel's 10th gen
i7 processor
wi-fi 6 16 gigabytes of ram
and the most important part that makes
this
laptop great the dedicated 1650 ti
graphics card this is something you
simply can't get
on any 13-inch macbook so getting such a
good card
and a 1800 premium ultrabook is
impressive just look at the difference
in graphics performance compared to
apple's 2020 13-inch macbook pro
and it's all thanks to the dedicated
graphics it even beat out the 16-inch
macbook
pro in terms of the unigine heaven
gaming benchmark
so i decided to do some gaming on the
razer and i was surprised to see that i
got a pretty smooth and consistent
50-60 fps while playing call of duty war
zone
and that's great for a laptop this thin
and portable
the only downside was that there was a
bit of coil whine in the fan noise which
did get annoying
but i'm sure that it won't bother gamers
much if they're using headphones
and on the flip side for creative
professional work
the razer didn't score as well as the
macbook pro
but it still performed decently well so
for something like video editing
it'll do great i was also very happy to
see that the blade stealth
came with an extremely fast ssd which
was faster than the one on the macbook
pro
which is unusual since macbooks used to
come with much faster ssds
so good job razer basically with
everything i said
going into account if you don't have a
software preference
and you could go with either windows or
mac os then i would honestly say that
the razer blade stealth 13
is the better laptop and the number one
reason for that
is the fact that you cannot get a
dedicated graphics card
on the 13-inch macbook pro so that means
you can't really game on it
without buying an egpu setup and that's
the reason why the small amount of
gaming that i do
happens on my iphone when it could have
been on my macbook pro
if it had more graphics power so that's
what makes the razer so great
since you not only get great performance
for gaming and creative professional
work
but you also get a thin light and
portable design
alongside excellent build quality an
awesome
keyboard and the freedom to choose the
display you need
based on what you do so i think the
mixture of all of that
makes this razor blade stealth worth it
compared to cheaper windows laptops
and i can say with certainty that if i
wasn't attached to the wonderful and
reliable mac os
software that continues to make me favor
my macbook pro
this is honestly the windows laptop that
i would buy
even despite the couple of downsides
like the black finish
and the massive bottom display bezel so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this review
and if this video helped make a decision
on which one to buy
we'll have links to both of these
laptops down in the description below
and if you like this t-shirt you can
find it just below this video
thanks for watching and click that
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one
[Music]